[Musique]
ce matin il a ajouté l'ancien manceau
même s'il est très fort ça sent la
rentrée en musique voilà l'une des
originalités de ce nouveau gouvernement
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
présent la réunion a eu sa première
rentrée au collège elie wiesel du
chaudron après le tour de chauffe des
enseignants motivés via les classes
musique du collège et lui disent elles
du chaudron sa carrière et sa souffrance
est l'instrument clé
[Musique]
ouais
la président du département a le sourire
car depuis dix ans ces dispositifs
existent localement
[Applaudissements]
cet effet
[Musique]
ça fait vraiment que je fais ce qu'on me
donne et c'est la première fois que
l'allemagne
première et ça leur donne une confiance
en le lisant un projet et il repart en
battant seconde avec 9,7 un peu plus
d'assurance
tous les élèves faisaient vraiment à
l'instrument le collège pour finalement
tout handicapé l'histoire de la géo des
masses au temps du far lyonnais chaque
année une subvention d'intérêt
pédagogique est attribuée aux 77
collèges de l'île et selon les objectifs
la musique est au centre du rayonnement
de notre jeunesse des valeurs éducatives
encouragé par la collectivité
départementale
[Musique]
je nous offrant la possibilité à nos
jeunes d'avoir des moments stepanian
exprimer leurs potentialités
ça fait aussi partie des expressions est
un chantier va éduquer et former et à
partir également des potentialités que
nous avons chacun en jeu ne sont pas les
mêmes c'est que nos sources est bien à
l'acquisition d'un solo ou encore à la
rencontre des artistes des centaines
d'enfants ont la chance de grandir
chaque jour en musique
[Musique]